When you think of animated films, Disney is
the first company to come to mind because
their films have shaped our childhood.
Despite their longevity they sometimes don’t
get scenes right the first time around and
that’s why there are alternate versions
of scenes or even deleted scenes.
Recording segments and storyboarding a scene
only to decide to cut it from the film is
not uncommon.
Let’s take a look at some of your favorite
Disney films and the process behind these
changes.
Give us a like when you see your favorite
Disney film and don’t forget to subscribe
to Screen Rant for more great videos.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of 10 Disney
Movie Moments Deleted From The Final Cut.
Beauty and the Beast
Disney’s 1991 film, Beauty and the Beast
was the first animated film to be in the category
of Best Picture at the Oscars.
The film ultimately lost the award to Jonathan
Demme’s The Silence of the Lambs but it
did win Oscars for Original Score and Original
Song.
Maybe they wouldn’t have been as fortunate
if they kept the 11-minute version of the
song Human Again in there.
They ultimately cut the song to help move
the story but later released a shorter version
of the song on DVD in 2002.
So if you want a little more enchantment in
your life check it out.
Tangled
A storybook opening with the reveal of a story
is nothing short of clichéd and was even
mocked in the 2001 film Shrek.
When the filmmakers behind Tangled were working
on an opening sequence of their 2010 film
they did just that.
But remember filmmaking is a process and with
each step the film hopefully gets better.
In this deleted sequence the filmmakers did
pull ideas to use in final opening out of
the film including the teardrop from the sun.
So it was worth the extra steps.
Toy Story
Lee Unkrich moved from editor of Toy Story
to director of Toy Story 3 because of his
keen eye to story telling.
One example of this came from his choice to
delete a scene of Sid torturing Buzz and Woody
at his home in the original film.
He felt the audience would be too fond of
the main characters and wouldn’t want to
see them tortured, so he cut the torture and
went straight to the interrogation.
Smart move Unkrich, you made many of us cry
in Toy Story 3 when we thought our beloved
characters were doomed.
Moana
Disney’s 2016 animated film Moana splashed
into theaters and the hearts of theatergoers.
Some fans of the film would be surprised to
learn that there was another song that was
cut from the film.
The songs name was Warrior and Moana and Maui
actually did a duet together.
It was a way for the filmmakers to show the
two characters bonding but despite enjoying
the song they ultimately had to cut it out
of the film.
The Little Mermaid
The two most important scenes of a movie are
the first ten minutes and the last ten minutes.
The first ten you need to grab the audience’s
attention and the last ten you need them to
leave talking about the film.
In the final scene of The Little Mermaid the
filmmakers did just that but originally they
had some issues.
In an alternate version the film, the character
of Ursula wasn’t as scary during the ending.
She was much closer to their heroine’s scale,
which made her not as frightening.
Sleeping Beauty
In the film Sleeping Beauty, Princess Aurora
was cursed by Maleficent and her family were
told that before the sun sets on Aurora's
sixteenth birthday, she shall prick her finger
on the spindle of a spinning wheel and die.
In the film you hear a spooky vocal note calling
her to a spindle of a spinning wheel.
But it really wasn’t a musical note.
The films audio track was recorded on magnetic
tape and because of the poor quality you heard
that note instead of the word, which was actually
calling the name, “Aurora”.
Lilo & Stitch
Stitch is a mischievous character but he is
in no way is he evil but originally the animators
wanted him to be.
In a deleted scene Lilo shows Stitch her other
best friend Pudge the Fish and gives him a
kiss.
Instead of Stitch giving him a kiss too he
throws Pudge on the ground and before Lilo
can save him birds come and attack her.
The fish dies as Stitch watches laughing.
We know Stitch isn’t the sweetest guy in
the world but he’s not a killer.
Maybe the animators were having a bad day
when they wrote that scene.
The Emperor's New Groove
Like many other cut scenes from this list,
in The Emperor's New Groove featured another
scene was a little too violent.
Warriors gathered together to practice the
destruction of Pacha's Village.
This dark and irrelevant scene was animated
but then later cut out due to being unnecessary.
Luckily the sarcastic Emperor Kuzco learned
his evil ways and became a better ruler before
they had a chance to execute his plans.
Robin Hood
There have been many versions of Robin Hood
made and it seems like a few different endings
for Disney’s 1973 animated film too.
At the end of the film when a fire engulfs
Robin Hood he is hurt by an arrow and Little
John carries him away.
As Prince John follows blood droppings into
a church he finds Maid Marion tending to Robin’s
wounds.
He offers to take away Robin’s pain as he
reveals a dagger and she bravely tells him
not to come closer.
Then King Richard arrives and ends Prince
John tyranny.
We kinda like this ending more, what about
you?
Frozen
It’s hard to imagine Elsa being anything
but the lovable character she is on screen
but that is not the case.
Originally she was meant to be the villain
but someone at Disney wised up and saw the
potential of a story between sisters.
In a deleted scene she uses her powers to
lift and torture two guards for information
showing a very evil side.
Do you prefer good Elsa or evil Elsa?
We think Disney preferred good Else due to
the box office success of Frozen.
There you have it, 10 Disney Movie Moments
Deleted From The Final Cut.
Did we miss any of your favorite bloopers?
Sound off in the comments below and remember
to subscribe to Screen Rant for more awesome
videos.
Thanks for watching.